thanks very much for having me here
so the phrase generative AI did not
exist
a year ago I think now it's suddenly
all the rage
so to really put things into context for
what generative AI means for search and
what some of the organizing principles
are about when we think about this
I want to take you back to the distant
past really long time ago to late
Thanksgiving of last year right this is
when
you know the bombshell literally dropped
on Twitter when you know they said
there's something called chat GPD come
give it a spin tell us what you like 10
o'clock that morning I think
couple hours later I tweeted something
like this right I was absolutely you
know mind blown and this is somebody
who's actually played with systems like
Lambda two years before that at Google
and still it was absolutely impressive
how good chat GPT was and I really
thought that
Google Supremacy for information seeking
searches we'll talk about that soon was
suddenly threatened I think for the
first time ever
there was a new way of doing search
there was a new paradigm in town and I
think it it literally jolted us all into
into a lot of excitement
but having said all that I still think
that what we've witnessed so far and
what we're gonna you know what we've
been seeing in the last four months
really is the tip of the iceberg I think
there is an amazing amount of innovation
that's going to happen with respect to
generative AI the way it's used in
Search and my goal here is really not so
much to show you a particular system or
talk about one particular idea but to
give you both the background on what
where and how we got to where we are a
little bit and to talk about some
organizing principles about you know how
to think about search and how to think
about generative Ai and search together
first let me go back and ask why did why
was I mind blown right why do we really
think it was such a big breakthrough
you know if you think about it the
technology was very very evolutionary
very incremental Transformers came out
bird came out you know other things came
out you know things were things were
growing pretty linearly and suddenly we
see that
we landed at a point where even though
the technology was very incremental and
evolutionary the resulting user
experience was
stunningly revolutionary right and that
was one of the reasons I think it's a
real breakthrough
but if you think a little harder
something else also becomes apparent
right while the technology was
incremental and evolutionary
it was also complex but the user
experience was both revolutionary and
extremely simple right suddenly you know
we it's almost as if the web didn't
exist and we went back to a Unix
terminal where you're actually typing
questions and it's like a chat or one of
those things
pre-internet on Unix it was literally
text typing back and forth it was very
simple very level revolutionary and yet
it was very very powerful and very
useful when it works right
historically if you think about it
search technology has said many clever
breakthroughs this is not the first
breakthrough in search right you know
pagerank came along synonyms came and
knowledge panels happen Knowledge Graph
happened so many things happened but
with every such
Advanced what happened was search UI
actually got more crowded it didn't get
less crowded unlike unlike what we're
seeing today right
um here's an example right if you don't
know who Greg Abbott is it's the Texas
governor about a Blog from here uh on
the Texas capital right if I go to
Google and type Greg Abbott this is what
I see and everything that's in blue is a
clickable unit and there is so much
information packed into this besides the
official website for Greg Abbott there's
some top news stories there's a
Wikipedia links you know everything
about
when he was born where he was born who
his spouse is you know there's there's a
lot of stuff packed in there and if I
scroll down there's even more right
the kind of questions people have asked
when they talk about Greg Abbott uh Greg
Abbott's Facebook page Twitter page the
usual link set and just in case people
who are interested in Greg Abbott might
also be interested in Kari Lake for
example of Arizona there's a link for
that too right there's just so much
because
we will talk about why in a minute but
again continuing on Greg Abbott there's
even more his Twitter feed
Wikipedia link related searches some
images all kinds of things about Greg
Abbott right this is all in just one
page
if I take a step back and ask
what is all
what are the answers what are the
questions to which I'm given the answers
here and here's a sample of them right
in this page I listed out about 28 or
something and I actually ran out of
patience there's just 50 or so things
for which questions for which the
answers are here everything from you
know when was he born where was he born
whose spouse is how many children does
he have why is he on a wheelchair a
number of questions related very finely
very very
precisely the Greg Abbott but also in
the broader context of Greg Abbott Texas
governorship and and so on so this web
search result page has the answers to so
many questions about Greg Abbott and you
might wonder why right why has the UI
gotten so complex over the years why are
we getting so many pieces of information
you know thrown at us in one shot
the answer is actually very very simple
right it's simply because search engines
could never fathom what is the exact
intent with which you went and typed
Greg Abbott and of course it's a it's a
loop right as you start getting results
about Greg Abbott's birthplace and his
spouse you're not going to go and type
Greg Abbott's
spouse right you're going to type Greg
Abbott and you know where to look so we
are in this feedback loop with Google
and Bing and other search engines which
has resulted in the situation where
search engines don't know exactly why we
type A Certain string in particular
search engines don't know our intent
therefore they optimize for what seems
natural which is the fewest keystrokes
to get you to the answer that you care
about it could be a click or it could be
a piece of information directly on there
and sometimes the answer the number is
actually zero right if you if I really
wanted to know where Greg Abbott was
born I don't need to type anything more
than Greg Abbott odds or I might even
get it with just Abbott right the
information is there if I know where to
look so because search engines could not
fathom the search intent the intent
behind the strings that the user typed
they've gone into this
position of creating a huge
overload of information and the UI
actually reflects that right and that's
that's the way things have been evolving
and which is why I think chat GPT
highlights one of the amazing things
that
large language models can do for us
large language models never been large
language models natural language
allows you to cut through all the
Clutter you can actually if only search
engines work perfectly with natural
language
you could actually say exactly what you
want if you know if you're looking for
Greg Abbott's birthplace you could say
Greg Abbott's where was Greg Abbott born
and you'll get the answer and you do get
the answer for that right but that's one
of the most amazing things about natural
language it lets you say what you want
and if search engines are good enough to
handle that you will get exactly what
you're looking for
and that's one of the things that chat
GPT
placed front and center right because
the experience was that of a chat you go
and type you don't go and type Greg
Abbott into chat GPT you actually say
why you are thinking about Greg Abbott
or
what exactly it is that you want to know
about Greg abbatrick so the slight
change in the UI paradigm unlock this or
unblocked our way of thinking from
keywords to stating our intent which is
which is if you think about it that's
the whole point of a search the search
is really to you have some underlying
intent or a goal that you want to
satisfy and the point of going to search
engine is really to to to do that and by
that little shift in the UI setting your
expectation to ask what you want using
natural language chat GPS opened your
eyes to this idea that you know natural
language processing is so good we could
actually put into real work instead of
cluttering a UA with lots and lots of
relevant but not needed details
of course that comes with a huge
responsibility right the moment you open
up this kind of expectation people are
going to ask all kinds of things right
you're going to type maybe your life
story and ask things right for example
um you know you're going to go and ask
things like do I need Apache beam if I'm
going to use
data flow on Google Cloud right this
kind of question is something that you
phrase if you expect the search engine
to understand what it is that you want
and two have the ability to hone in and
pull the right kind of information for
you right so this this contract between
users and search engines has been
revised in a very intriguing way and
that and that is that is
with the ability to
comprehend what the user is saying and
get the right amount of information in
the right way with the right summaries
or other other forms
expectations are now set extremely high
right so that's that's the uh that's
that's the outcome of you know this this
two-way contract being changed ever so
slightly
fortunately of course we know that large
language models are actually a two-way
street right and this is this is
something that I think is less
appreciated in in you know most of the
wisdom that you see on the on the
internet and by this by this I mean two
things right everybody of course Raves
about how
um gpt3 can write the Gettysburg address
in the form of a wrap right that's
totally fun we all love it right but you
know we we are awed by its
abilities with respect to its output but
what is certainly getting hidden is the
fact that it's actually amazingly good
at processing what it is that you asked
it in the first place right that means
that
in the context of search language models
allow us to become really expressive ask
exactly what it is that we want and
the synthesis part is nice right
summarization is nice you know the by
now I think we're all probably tired of
chat GPT telling us
paragraph one paragraph two overall blah
blah blah blah right that's the that
structure is that's almost evolved there
which is nice which is wonderful but the
less appreciated part in my opinion is
that it allows users to ask questions
very naturally in ways that are very
awkward to do on say Google searches
so to sum it all up I'll say this right
so for what's happened in in in the last
four months uh which is kind of
mind-boggling if you think about it four
months is really we've been told
there's a new paradigm for searching on
the internet for knowledge on the
internet don't search with keywords ask
what you want right so that's that's
kind of nice and clear at this point
but the more important question of
course is what is it what does it mean
for the future is it really game over
and I'm sure you agree with me when I
say you know it's not even the beginning
and in fact I alluded to this this is
just the starting point there's a
there's a long way to go let's first
start by
looking at what I think are the most
common and maybe even easy arguments
against generative AI in search right
the first and I think the well
understood part is really that
the fluency in language that comes from
large language models often mask
inaccuracies factual inaccuracies when
you do search with llms so what what
does that mean here's a here's uh before
I get to an example
you know a very quick overview of what
an llm is again I'm assuming every one
of you knows it but I'll say it right
llm is a great next word predictor you
could get technical and talk about
tokens but think of it as a next word
predictor statistical next word
predictor right and the thing I'll say
is that when the statistically most
likely sequence of next words
happens to be the right answer they look
magical right if I go to llms and ask
you know how many uh what are the movies
for which Jennifer Lawrence won an Oscar
award it's going to nail it it's going
to tell you exactly what the movies are
mainly because
the training data for gpt3 or Bard
consists of lots and lots of web pages
that talk about Jennifer Lawrence the
movies that she won an Oscar for and all
of that right so you're going to get
that and it's doing it purely
statistically it's not like your query
was perfectly understood and you know
um
decomposed into you know the units and
entities and all of that none of that
right it's really the statistically most
if it's almost like saying Jennifer
Lawrence won an Oscar far and the next
most likely sequences happen to be the
right answer and they look wonderful and
of course when that doesn't happen you
know they look they look anywhere from
uh crazy to to you know maybe even
dangerous so I think today's petition
for for passing AI kind of reflects the
fact that things could get dangerous if
L alums don't do start start
hallucinating right
here's a quick example right let's just
added this for a moment
so I had a question about Island touring
right so I wanted to know
um you know who are the PhD students of
Alan Turing so I asked the question and
you can start with this go do your own
Google searches and you'll soon find out
that
of the five maybe one or one and a half
answers are right the others had nothing
to do with Talent touring in fact some
of them came well after Allen touring's
time I think strategy may be in other
others as well somehow in the memory
space of you know chart GPT Alan Turing
British mathematician Christopher
strachy computer scientist
um you know also British Etc came
together somewhere something collided
and it made up a very convincing
paragraph that Christopher strategy was
Alice Alan turing's student and of
course you know like any good
computer centers I was
curious to know if Alan Turing was
actually a good PhD advisor was he a
successful PhD advisor and now the
stories get even more interesting right
Alan Turing really cared about his
students they let them think
independently oh no no no right this is
all lovely fun stuff entirely made up
and of course you know if you didn't
know that Allen touring had maybe one or
one and a half PC students you would
think oh this is this is awesome right
but again I'm not saying anything new
that you know nobody here knows about
all of you know that this is this is
what gpd3 chat GPT does we are aware of
it Hallucination is a well-known well
understood not well understood well
acknowledged problem at least when it
comes to
using llms per search
but the less well understood part of
search I'll say is how do you use llms
to build search systems right llms in
their in their native form or really
next word predictors you could use them
to answer questions by posting them as
questions and looking at the
statistically likely sequences of
answers but what is the search system a
search system is something that should
be optimized for giving the right answer
it should be optimized for getting you
complete the task that you care about
and we'll talk about what kind of tasks
we care about in a moment
and let's not make any mistake all of
these are actually search systems chat
GPT Sydney and bard of course gpd3 by
itself is not a search system it's a
pure llm but when it go when you go from
gpd3 to chat GPT there is a certain kind
of fine tuning that has happened and
that is using you know reinforcement
learning using human feedback to produce
certain kinds of behaviors
um you know nice words like alignment
get thrown around but ultimately what
you're doing is you are fine tuning it
and taking it from a model to a system
so let's talk about what you know how to
build search systems using llms but more
importantly let's actually revisit the
question of what is search
right
here's a quote I say it in I say quote
in quotes because it's not really a
quote I think Lotso actually said
something else that's kind of like this
but I might have asked GPT to make it
for me but anyway it's a it's a
reasonable reasonable summary of what
the search is right the search is
actually a journey you are going towards
something it's not it's not an end goal
in itself but it's actually a step
towards something
so when you think about search of course
you know you all naturally think about
Google no question about it we think
about Microsoft Bing which is a
fantastic search engine
think about some of the new players in
the market like Neva and some of the old
players in the market like Doug Duggar
these are all perfectly good search
engines you should think about them when
you think about search but don't stop
there right there is a lot more search
happening on there happening on the web
out there that's not captured by the
four or four examples that I mentioned
in particular think about all these
places where search happens right and
I'm not even including ones like YouTube
here right
um I partitioned them into three buckets
based on different types of
characteristics But ultimately these are
all places where a lot of search happens
and these are all places where people go
to search for many many things right you
go to Thomas net if you have a hydraulic
press that needs a part that's missing
right you go to
Stubhub if you want to buy tickets to a
game at exorbitant prices
um you know this is the kind of places
where you go and search and you're
finding things and you're getting things
done here right and that again it
touches retail marketplaces clutch is a
place where you can go and hire
developers right that's again ultimately
an intent satisfying uh search
experience
we can also think about the data types
of two kinds of things we talked about
search intents earlier I mentioned
search engines
there are many different kinds of them
and I think it's worth keeping keeping
these clear in our heads for example
there's web search as done by Google and
Bing and others there's site search you
go to some website there is a site
there's a search box that lets you
search the content of that site
you could have listing search which is
typically the kind of things they showed
in the previous slide lots and lots of
you know expedias and the airbnbs indeed
all of these places where there's a
whole bunch of listings of many
different types that you're searching
through
this Enterprise search which is a
different base where you're searching
through the Corpus within an
organization with its own privacy
controls and access controls and a bunch
of things to slack channels and whatnot
search can be crawled like Google or
Bing or hosted like Zillow or indeed or
latent in some cases
imagine and I don't think we've even
scratched the surface of the latent part
imagine there is imagine the entire CRM
database the customer database of a
company is crawled indexed and you know
search searchable right there's a whole
bunch of knowledge in there that is not
visible through any search engine today
and that's actually a shame and I think
that that's probably going to change
soon
search engines can be flat or sliced
like in Google where you have images and
videos and news and other things are
faceted like you see on e-commerce sites
search intents also come in many
different shapes and sizes this
navigational which says you know you
want to go to United Airlines web page
you go to Google type United it'll take
you there Chrome takes you there
actually
informational this is again a very large
class of searches where you are trying
to find information about some topic
again the information can be very
coarse grained or very short-lived or
something that's you know that you
engage in for a very long time
it can be transactional everything from
download the latest version of duckdb
for Ubuntu Linux right that's a very
transactional search you know when you
search for duckdb for Ubuntu Linux
the underlying intent is a transaction
right it's not just you don't want to
learn about the history of Doug DB for
Ubuntu Linux you want to actually
download it and get on with your with
your life right that's a different kind
of search intent
search intents also has single versus
multiple outcomes in the case of the
duck DB on Ubuntu it's a single outcome
you're going to install it and move on
if you're applying for a job it's a
longer lived search
it's got multiple outcomes you know you
might look at multiple job listings
conversely for recruiters looking for
candidates they're looking for multiple
candidates not just you know one
as I said it could be short-lived or
long-lived so there is again the intent
could be a task intent complete
something versus browse you know
browsing is a perfectly good use of
search to learn about some things learn
about options availability and so on so
you know there's there's a whole
um
I'll summarize it by saying that search
is a very messy and very
multi-dimensional thing right and to
think about llms in this context what
what do we how do we organize these into
some basic
principles so that we can actually start
talking about what's the role of llms in
these things and how llms could
potentially change the shape of shape
search
so I'm going to talk about
two ideas
the ideas of a answer and a decision
which I think is one of the most
important and valuable organizing
principles to take away from here
by very coarsely and Loosely placing
search engines search intents all of
them into these two types I think we'll
gain a lot of insight into what llms and
generative a can do for search and
the short summary for what's about to
come is that pure language models are
probably going to be good for an
increasingly larger and larger fraction
of answer searches but they're not going
to help you a whole lot with decision
searches okay we'll talk about them in a
minute
and we'll point out one of the
fundamental barriers for llms to solve
the latter
and tell us to tell you a little bit
about what we're doing again not meant
to be an informational for what we're
doing at our company but I'll tell you
the the somewhat technical position that
we've taken here and I'll conclude with
the slide where I hallucinate about what
the future might bring about
so at a very very course level I want to
think about searches two kinds of things
happening right one is
think of generative AI in the context of
search as an interactive Wikipedia
something that you can interact with
nearly endlessly ask
fine-grained questions Focus questions
as per clarifications zoom in zoom out
Etc but
to A first order of approximation think
of it as an interactive Wikipedia it's a
conversation on a drop topic very broad
very narrow and it can drift as it
evolves right I can start talking about
Greg Abbott and quickly talk about
gun control in California right it's
very easy to have that kind of drift in
a conversation and that's that's what I
call an interactive Wikipedia model for
answers
the second one is what I call the
decision maker model where you are
exploring options related to a
goal-oriented task
you want to look through a database of
listings
learn about that space of products or
things and you're going to make one or a
few choices so this is my first cut
approximation of the two types of
searches and and I think this
this dichotomy is valuable because it
helps us think about
what elements can do what generative AI
can do in a somewhat principled way
between the between the two classes here
again the examples are
self-explanatory I don't need to read
the mode for you in the first case again
you can learn about very complex topics
or very recent topics like the Oscars
you you might explore a topic over a
longer period of time you know Carbon
sequestration is something that you
might learn for about 20 minutes but
diabetes is something that people might
learn about for a much longer time
basketball scores again very short-lived
small information need right these are
all good examples of interactive
Wikipedia model
the other kind is you know you want to
buy a hair dryer or you're looking to
apply for a job or you're renting an
apartment or hydraulic press replacement
parts right in all of these cases you
need to browse you need to decide you
need to act and this to me is a very
important distinction
especially when it comes to the role of
language models because the second class
not only has text
or text and images but it also has a lot
of structured information at various
granularities right and the information
could be very very precise fine-grained
saying that this is the model number for
this part as opposed to a text that
talks about something more qualitatively
so the we know from from having played
with chat GPT for for four months or so
and bought for four weeks or so they are
actually pretty good for many topics
many topics that are well represented in
the training Corpus right and we talked
about how they might hallucinate for
tail topics
and
we do know also that fine tuning can
help significantly by fine tuning I
don't just mean fine tuning on
again you can fine tune on a corpus in
the data sense take the llm fine tune it
for you know data on everything about
music or everything about politics
you're going to get a better llm which
can answer questions much better on that
Corpus of objects
you can inject fresh data continue the
fine tuning so that it can answer
questions about recent events and again
this process is fine tuning and figuring
out the right objective right so once
you keep doing that with data it's going
to get better with that Corpus
you could also do instruction fine
tuning and I think that's the other
very valuable knob that llms have and
this is this is the part that I think
makes it more magical and this is not
just again
writing the Gettysburg address and wrap
style but you could actually do
you could actually do more more
interesting things with with instruction
fine tuning
um
again there are subtle differences
between the Florence tale instruction
fine tuning on a bunch of natural
language tasks Express this instructions
this the instruct GPD kind which is a
broader set of natural language
instructions and Chain of Thought
prompting which is a very promising idea
because you want to
you want to teach the llm
apologies for anthropomorphizing it a
little bit but you want to teach the
aluminum to make at least one or two
steps of reasoning here right
you know all of this is reasonable in
the interactive Wikipedia model because
once you once you do a fair bit of
fine-tuning of various kinds
you start seeing the so-called emergent
abilities like
um
chaining two steps of reasoning
occasionally three steps and of course I
think I'm not even going to touch upon
the question of can they do
multiplication and additional and
Division and so on I think that's uh
that's an exercise that's not going to
get us anywhere
but from the Viewpoint of
interactive Wikipedia style browsing of
information it is possible to fine-tune
LMS but they will still have a lot of
difficulty with very specific entities
on the other side of the story in the
decision maker model you know when I
went to buy a set of kitchen knives for
for our for our home this is what the
picture approximately looked like right
and browsing results opening a tab for
new results Google about something
because they read a phrase there called
santoku knife I didn't know what a
santoku knife was so I wanted to go
learn about it and once I knew what a
santoku knife was I really wanted it so
I went back and started changing my
search and I wanted to be able to say
things like I want a knife set that has
a tomato knife because we use a lot of
tomatoes and that has a santoku knife
because I just read about it and it
seems like an awesome way to chop
carrots right this is this is the pretty
significant thing and for this one
kitchen knife set I quickly realized I
had 23 tabs open and shuttling between
Google and the various various providers
this is how a decision maker searches
with multiple intents and so on
and here out of the box language models
are essentially useless right you could
go and ask what is the sun Toco knife
and you'll get a good answer but
um
very micro topics start to matter very
very precise details start to matter and
you know if an llm can't answer
questions about Alan Turing PhD students
which is a well represented topic on the
web right it should be easy for not easy
I mean it should be
easier for an llm to say no Alan Turing
didn't have
too many PhD students right but yet you
know you see that it makes up makes up
information uh fine grain Details Matter
the the discussion often gets into very
Niche vocabulary on very very uh you
know tiny little things
and more importantly the data has
structured and unstructured information
right part numbers number of bedrooms in
an apartment or
prerequisites for a job application some
job might say you need 10 years of
experience in C plus plus you know these
kind of details are very hard to
pinpoint exactly with an llm and that's
that's a big Challenge and I think we're
going to see a lot of
both commercial as well as research
Innovations in in this space
but more importantly there's a
fundamental reason why llms I think will
struggle here
and that's the fact that they cannot
ground their
um ground the conversation in real life
entities you know I don't want to get
all philosophical and talk about sensory
inputs and so on but
um
when an llm talks about Island touring
it's talking about the string Allen
touring which showed up as a bunch of
characters it doesn't have
a real grounding of Alan Turing as the
British mathematician you know who who
helped
um the the Allies win the World War II
in a certain way right it doesn't have
these things it doesn't have a Knowledge
Graph inside of it right although the
way the conversation looks it looks like
it understands who Alan Turing is what
he did Etc but that that grounding
doesn't happen whether intentionally or
accidentally it certainly looks
accidentally like it does have a
grounding of these things but um
we know that that's that's not the case
so this is going to be a significant
limiting factor on the decision maker
model where you need absolutely grounded
discussions when I say
um you know
Cuisinart coffee maker of certain type
I'm talking exactly about that I'm not
talking about anything else I'm not
talking about coffee makers in general
or and so on so the inability of
elements to ground their discussions on
very concrete entities
makes it even harder when you deal with
things like e-commerce because the
number of entities there is very very
large and it grows very fast right it
needs to develop an internal model of
how these entities are organized
according to certain facets or
taxonomies and so on so that that's
going to be a big Challenge and again I
hope to see lots of innovation here
it's one of my favorite examples if
you're doing an apartment search and you
say two bedroom San Francisco apartment
within walking distance to Bart
there's so much going on here right
there are structured constraints on the
number of bedrooms there are geospatial
constraints
and it assumes what we'll call a world
model right and the idea that Bart is
not one entity it represents a bunch of
train stations in San Francisco and
walking distance to Bart is really the
disjunction of all of them meaning that
as long as I'm able to walk to a bot
station I'm happy in in seeing that
listing for this query so this kind of
things require uh you know a lot of lot
of additional knowledge additional World
model that llms can't handle and of
course it makes it even harder because
at that moment in time the database
might have some things that are walkable
to a bot station some things that are
not walkable to BART station to to be
able to make the distinction on the
flying say a bigger challenge
so I want to talk a little bit about
what what then I mean so what if an
alums can't do it how are we going to
solve this and how do we put the best of
generative AI to work in in this
decision maker experience and how do we
make it better
here's a bit of a markup right um this
is pick up your phone and start chatting
like you chat with a friend and you say
help me find an apartment in San
Francisco an ideal assistant or search
engine will tell you
because this is an under specified query
the intent is intent space is very large
say something like do you have specific
neighborhoods or types of apartments in
mind
and then the user should be able to say
what or not just what how they think of
it right I commute to the peninsula a
lot I want to be close to the Bay Bridge
and then
the engine goes to work and finds some
things for for you and it presents
something in a form like this which
let's say you're you can scroll
horizontally and you know save or
shortlist or do a bunch of things then
the user notices that you know they're
looking for a two bedroom that's that's
one way to to
make the query more specific so they add
something there
and again you get a bunch of results
browse them
I click on one of them I see something
like this I scroll down see something
more I close this little window go back
to the search then I have a question
about the second engine second listing
very specifically and it has the
question is Geneva Avenue a quiet
neighborhood now this is where it gets
very tricky right because now
I'm talking about a specific Street in
San Francisco there's a lot of context
and I'm talking about in the context of
the second listing here which mentions
uh Geneva Avenue so
here again some an ideal search engine
would bring bring results like this
and continue the conversation with more
questions and answers and then maybe
take one more question
and this time actually I wanted to
answer give me information that's very
relevant to that I said what's the
nearest bot station
then I want the answers not just generic
answers I want Apartments annotated by
their walking distance to BART station
this is what you know a good good search
experience I anticipate will look like
very very soon
if it if you kind of reflect on this
there are a couple of core elements here
one is that there's a seamless
interleaving of results and
conversations
there's a lot of other UI elements like
scrolling filtering saving sharing this
is again table Stakes right you
absolutely need them
you want Rich conversations about
individual results about the categories
you know for example if you're if you're
buying one of these projectors you might
want to learn about it you may say what
are the types of
projectors I can use for watching movies
at home and they come in so many price
points so you want to understand what do
you get for the price points right being
able to research a product category is
important World Knowledge becomes
important
you might want to add or undo
constraints you tried something and then
you say okay that's good then you say
you know what actually I don't care
about steel finish anymore give me any
finish that's okay so this is all
managing that state accumulated
preferences all this is going to be
absolutely critical in doing this
and of course you'll need very important
bells and whistles like longer lived
sessions because these things are not
something that you finish in one go
sometimes you come back to it and do
things executable actions are going to
be important okay that sounds good book
the ticket right you want to be able to
execute it so this is this is sort of
the life story of a decision making
search session if you will and that's
something that llms will make make a big
big
big contribution to so here I'm going to
talk a little bit about our particular
position and how to do this
and again it's got a nice underlying
principle this one is actually real it's
a real code that somebody said so I
didn't charge GPD didn't make it up for
me
so our key Insight is that llms actually
I mean in our stack we use llms in many
different places at least five different
places if I if you remember right and
one of the core use cases is these are
amazing compilers in particular they can
make beautiful language to language
Transformations and that's something
that's
underutilized in the in the in the use
of llms right they can write code we
know they can write code because well I
know because they use it often to write
code for for our company
the graded language Transformations and
can be trained relatively easily so the
one thing we do first is we take a
corpus that we are building a search
engine for we bring in World knowledge
related to the Corpus in the form of
text in the form of images in the form
of structured data
um
we use llms as compilers we digest all
this and generate a database of facts
think of the database as the same
listing Corpus that we start with
augmented by a lot of extra facts
related to each of the listings there
and this is this is like a gigantic part
of our processing Pipeline and one of
the things that we're particularly proud
of to to take a lot of knowledge here
and create this database
and of course once the stat chat starts
our agent starts talking to this and of
course the core of it is a clean search
experience and one thing that we are
moving toward is how do we clearly
differentiate the calls to the backend
search engine and how do you conduct a
conversation for World Knowledge and
that is handled by this agent carefully
and
of course we bring in an llm like chat
GPT or Bard as a call out when we want
World Knowledge so for example
you know if you want to know something
like is would say example here it is is
Jennifer Avenue Geneva Avenue a quiet
street and that is something that we
call out to Bard or Google or different
kinds of backends so we bring that into
the conversation flow and this this is
approximately how our system is
architected of course the part that we
built so far is the core search system
and this is just the starting point of
something more exciting that we're
building a tornado
and of course this is the chat that this
is a slide that I added hurriedly after
I uploaded my deck last week because
chat GPD just said oh there's something
called plugins right so in anticipation
of possible question here I added this
this notion which is that
charge GPD brings an application into a
chat to augment the chat right
through a simple APA whatever API the
developer of that application exposes
our strategy is the complementary
strategy which is to bring conversation
into a search browsing experience on an
application Corpus if you go to a
listing search site any of them
hopefully will power this kind of
capabilities to to bring World Knowledge
and conversation abilities to search
again browsing that that Corpus
understands the application Corpus
deeply and uses llms to bring the world
knowledge as well as fluency as well in
particular our research engine we built
for a corpus automatically becomes a
chat GPT plugin that can talk to chat
GPD as well okay
the key thing people should remember is
that on chat GPT the quality of the
experience is going to depend on how
good the underlying search engine is
that it's calling out to and that's
something that comes out automatically
in the wash when we build a search
engine using our methodology
so what I've said so far is
I called attention to high-level
dichotomy in search answers and
decisions and
we pointed out that generative AI brings
a major way to reimagine the search user
experience
so far it's a great tool for the
interactive Wikipedia model of answers
and we've taken a stab at describing our
architecture for the decision maker
search of course it's all work in
progress there's lots of evolution
that's going to happen from here on out
but let me conclude with one crazier
thought right
if you look back at the web it's been
awesome at the presentation layer right
there's so much Innovation from HTML
pages to JavaScript to react and flutter
and all the beauty beauty that has
happened
it's also great at transactions you can
buy you can you can buy tickets to an
event you can book a restaurant
reservation
people have bought cars people buy homes
online so transactionally it's been
awesome as well but
the web is not capability Centric right
but the question is what if it were and
because of the way it evolved
publish a website let a search engine
crawl it index it and let people search
you know that Paradigm has worked pretty
well so far
but it is possible that with generative
AI the web can be different from how it
is today in particular everybody builds
their own
for want of a better word I'll simply
call it a chat bot exposing the
capabilities of that site or that app
and these chat Bots start talking to
each other and a search engine there is
a very different kind of Beast it's a
routing engine it's a decision making
engine we're going to see all this very
very soon maybe as you know it took us
about 30 years from the beginning of the
web to where we are today but getting to
something like this might happen in
three years or five years we'll see
thank you so much
[Music]